I was out here all alone once
bruce made me go out into the forest by myself for
the first time i had no idea what was out there
he was just a boy those were
the lessons that he taught you
bruce was a psychopath using
fear to control everyone
you need to make sure that this
doesn't happen to someone else
Batman's ally was found dead tonight
it's over for me be a better batman
barbara welcome back to gotham dick batman's
gone gotham it's mine now we're investigating
this new red hood case it was he said
be a better batman the titans got this
you know how crazy that is right trying to step
into your father's shoes i do commissioner gordon
Whole world is turned upside down i think
i'm losing my mind if you're gonna dub
i'm gonna hawk we need to stop him for cases
like these we've been using a consultant
scarecrow doctor crane
Dick Grayson red hood is a biblical brother
the king moves stealthily in the shadows
while the ponds are sent to the teeth of
destruction it's just his opening move
where i come from you come after family
we show no mercy
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
titan season 3 trailer video they're getting ready
to drop the season on hbo max remember all those
dc shows are on hbo max now so basically this is
batman passing the mantle to nightwing in season
three like he just became nightwing during season
two got the brand new costume now batman's like
you know what you could be the new batman now be
a better batman than i was there's a whole bunch
of easter eggs here so we'll break it all down
a lot of this should feel very familiar if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos there's a lot of batman
stuff happening in the next year between this
we have the robert pattinson batman movie coming
up next year and they're still in the middle of
filming the flash movie with the michael keaton
batman and the ben affleck batman as we speak
right now in fact they actually just released
some pictures of the flash the ezra miller flash
inside michael keaton's bat cave of course
they brought back the classic 1989 batmobile
i will mention that stuff later in the video
because we will be getting a trailer for the flash
movie sometime later this year but they opened the
trailer with the story of dick grayson driving to
the woods outside wayne manor because remember
batman basically owns all this land around the
batcave so this is like the back road to get into
the batcave they're cutting the footage out of
order so he's telling this footage to scarecrow
after he learns that scarecrow is working for the
gotham city police department from inside prison
to help them solve cases scarecrow being played by
vincent carthizer most of you will remember him
as pete from mad men he's done a couple other
things but most people remember him from mad men
so it'll be interesting to see what his version of
scarecrow is like he's kind of gone full hannibal
lecter in titan season 3. in the story he talks
about how batman made him go out into the woods by
himself basically to face his fears it's implied
that the child that you see in the trailer is part
of that flashback but it could be another child
just because they've shown a couple of different
versions of young dick grayson in the series so
far scarecrow starting the trailer off with this
whole idea of batman using fear on little kids the
idea that he's this terrible dad they're sort of
using that to build up to this moment where red
hood gets killed while he's investigating
this joker crime and then becomes red hood
like they want to pin it on batman as if he's
somehow responsible for this happening and it
does look like he blames himself like peace i'm
out no more obviously very apropos that he talks
about how batman uses fear to control everyone
because he is the scarecrow he very literally
tries to use fear like he has his fear toxin
that he was using on everyone and when red hood
gets killed by the joker here in what looks like
their version of amusement mile in gotham city
it looks like someone has been jokerized
i believe joker's serum is actually based
on scarecrow's fear toxin like there's some of the
fear toxin inside of joker's serum they show you a
little bit inside the batcave again it's been
a while since we've been in there but there's
also some images of nightwing walking around and
you can see jason todd's robin costume hanging up
like they're looking at it as if it's some sort of
specter of the past like some ghost that's staring
at them judging them it'll remind you that seeing
a batman v superman with ben affleck's batman
staring at the dead robin costume even though
that was meant to be dick grayson in the zack
snyder continuity the way zack snyder explained it
that was the whole reason why he added the joker
to the justice league snyder cut in that ending
scene because there's a brief moment before evil
superman shows up where he and joker sort of have
it out over what happened to their respective
sidekicks in the past joker starts throwing dick
grayson's death in his face and then batman throws
harley quinn's death in joker's face she begged
me to kill you zack snyder actually said that the
studio was kind of pissed that he started adding
all that new stuff to the end of the movie but he
was like screw you guys i'm doing it anyway the
only thing that he couldn't add back in was that
green lantern scene i've talked about that in a
couple of my other videos so i'll post some links
for that down in the description because he has
since revealed what that was going to look like it
was basically going to be the debut of jon stewart
in dc movies but the whole thing is that warner
brothers had their own version of jon stewart
that they were going to introduce in some upcoming
project like the green lantern corps movie that we
have coming up in the next couple of years so they
basically threatened to not release the snyder
cut if he kept green lantern in the movie but
then during titans when they're reporting on jason
todd's death you actually see a bunch of people's
reactions as they sort of go around the city this
is actually meant to be the show's version of tim
drake so obviously he is the next robin but
it seems like just based on the footage he's
still a ways off from becoming the next robin the
team has a little bit of a reunion it seems like
they've all kind of been doing their own thing
for just a little while the way they play this
scene too this is obviously dick grayson inside
wayne manor and they imply that batman has either
killed joker with the bloody crowbar that he used
to kill jason todd or he's done something really
bad with it like he's gone to a very dark place
i don't know how dark they're gonna take this
version of batman like there are certain rules
about what you do and do not do with batman
no matter where he's being used and what kind
of project i think the idea here is that he just
got off the deep end and done something really
bad with the crowbar that was used by joker to
kill jason todd like he did something really bad
to joker as far as i know they haven't revealed
who's playing their version of joker on titans
but i think we'll just see that when they actually
drop the episodes he's not really supposed to be
a huge character during season three but maybe
during future seasons then it seems like there's
some kind of small time jump and dick grayson goes
back to barbara gordon who is now commissioner
and they're kind of doing the batman beyond thing
only in batman beyond it was like a much older
version of barbara gordon who become the same
age as her father jim gordon when he became
commissioner batman beyond was meant to be in
the distant future so it's like an 80 something
batman so that was like 40 50 years in the future
from the timeline of where you saw the batman the
animated series stuff with batman and his prime
but as you can see this version of barbara gordon
is in a wheelchair so she's kind of become more of
an oracle figure combining the oracle version of
her character with the commissioner gordon version
of her character because she seems a little
bit older than dick grayson i don't know if
they're going to imply that they have some sort of
romance in the past but clearly it's been a long
time since they had their version of the killing
joke so it seems like she hasn't been batgirl in a
while so i don't know if we'll see flashbacks with
her in the costume because that would actually be
pretty cool they actually just confirmed who's
going to be playing dc's version of batgirl in
the new batgirl movie that they're doing for hbo
max it's leslie grace she was just in that in the
heights movie which i haven't seen yet so i can't
really say anything about her performance or what
she's like as an actress i think they're doing it
this way just to have some parody with the matt
reeves version of batman because in that jeffrey
wright is their version of gordon so even though
that version of batman sort of exists in its own
continuity on earth too it's not in the same earth
as say like the justice league version of batman
with ben affleck i think logically they're trying
to do some place settings so that in the future
like many years down the road if they wanted to
do a big crossover with robert pattinson's batman
it would make a little more sense which versions
you're seeing on screen then like i said at least
a small time jump because it's been enough time
for jason todd to take on the red hood identity
either he's been resurrected or he's been in a
coma this whole time they haven't explained how
they're bringing him back like does he really die
and do they really throw him in the lazarus pit
like the classic story or are they doing something
a little bit different because as far as i know
they haven't said anything about doing racial
ghoul or the lazarus pits during titan season 3.
and as he says there's no more batman and gotham
anymore because he's sort of passed the mantle
to dick grayson and it seems like dick grayson
hasn't completely figured out how he's going to
handle all this so there's a power vacuum he says
batman's gone gotham is mine now and he starts
gunning down all these mob members it's a lot
like the plot of the under the red hood movie with
jason todd coming back to gotham after a period of
time and then just going after all the biggest
mobsters killing them on site all this footage
where starfire is talking about losing her mind
going crazy that's probably something that her
sister blackfyre is doing to her just to mess with
her like we see blackfyre later in the trailer and
what seems like some kind of containment device
trying to break out the whole thing with blackfyre
is that it actually seemed like she was supposed
to be the main villain of season three but she
might just be one of the antagonists and the
even weirder thing is that you actually see a
whole bunch of raven teaming up with her like you
see raven and all this armor that's made to look a
little bit like starfire in blackfyre's armor from
their home world i think the idea though is that
after red hood has it out with the batman family
and the titans again then he will eventually
become more of an anti-hero like he is in the
comics some other much bigger threat surfaces
that threatens them all and that's when he helps
them out i think they could still use a speedster
and the flash is getting ready for like season
eight so i feel like it's about time that they put
a speedster on titans eventually maybe when we get
to season four season five or something like that
big reminder about the suicide squad peacemaker
tv series that's gonna be dropping in january
it'll be a spin-off of the suicide squad movie
they haven't completely explained if it's a
prequel or a sequel but it'll be on hbo max i
will be doing episode videos for that when it
releases it'll be around the same time that marvel
is releasing their she-hulk series the whole thing
with the matt reeves batman hbo series that he's
doing there's a spin-off of his batman tv show
is that it sounds like it might not premiere to
like the end of next year or maybe even early 2023
but it will be set during batman year one because
the movie takes place during batman year two
and i will also do videos for the green lantern
hbo series but that's probably not gonna premiere
to like the fall of next year the next big series
that i'm doing videos for is marvel's what if
series on disney plus gonna be big multiverse
show based on all the craziness that happened
at the end of the loki series in the finale so
make sure you have alerts enabled so you don't
miss any of those episodes you can click here
for that new loki season 2 teaser and all the
kang deleted scenes and click here for my full
marvel what if trailer video in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!